Hi everyone, welcome to this week's episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast.
This week we are looking into EC3 at Monza, with your hosts for this week being Nova
and myself, Peter.
I feel like starting off at the weekend, we had Bondarev in some of the test sessions which
would have been quite interesting to see him. I'm not too sure what happened to him.
Um, apparently he was always just meant to only be testing, is what I've heard,
but he was just put on the entry list anyways.
He's also, I remember, I think it was Alp Aksoy on TikTok, he said,
going to miss you, so it may have seemed like, oh, that he's doing a mid-season move to somewhere,
given, quite frankly, Italian season has not gone to plan for him.
Yeah, especially with how it's just been for F4, where we expected him to be much stronger,
seeing him move up to the regional level would have been interesting.
When he showed what he could do in the UAE, and in the main season, he just completely flopped,
being outperformed by less experienced teammates, and maybe there could have been a kind of
reset for him. So, I mean, maybe he’ll do FREC or something as well. We just have to see with him,
but it would be interesting to see him doing some form of regional races, because,
that's honestly his last hope.
Yeah, and during the testing, he didn't actually do too bad for himself. Most of the time,
it was within, it was, he would have been just out of like, the point scoring sort of positions.
It was like, I remember in one of the tests, he was like, P13, P14, or something like that.
Yeah, and for the first time in the EC3 car, at least Monza was a track he knows well, because,
you know, F4, they love Monza. Yeah, but then going into practice, I mean, MP were,
I think they've been used to Palou, or maybe they're used to dominating, and
they weren't looking too strong in practice. And, I mean, Campos have always kind of been,
they've been nowhere where we expected them to be this season. I mean, I know we've said that a lot,
but it's just been a lot of unexpected for this season. Yeah, and it also didn't help that I feel like
every time I went into, I check the live timing for like a practice session or something,
someone was like, stopped on the road, or somebody was like,
like, it was a yellow flag, it was being red flagged, and it's just like,
it's just Monza. You just have to accept that it's Monza, it's always going to be some form of like,
chaos. I'm surprised that there were eight red flags during the midweek testing, somehow.
What are these guys doing? How is this happening? Do they forget how to drive? Do they reach Monza,
and they forget how to turn? They step into the general vicinity of Monza and just get their
minds completely wiped on how they're meant to drive a car? Something in the Monza air.
Yeah, but then going into qualifying, I mean, it was a Palou Motorsport car on pole,
just not the one we expected. Yeah. I mean, where does Perard come from? He's been kind of under the
radar, he's not really done much notable this season, I feel like. He's just been there, but of course,
it's all been about. He's gotten a few podiums, maybe, but he's very much kind of been outside of
the points, maybe getting the top five. But it's like, it's not been solid, especially when you've
seen what his teammate has been able to do. Yeah, comparing Perard to people like Dall'Agnol and
Egozi, his results have been much lower down the order. It's interesting to see him get pole,
though. I think Robin wants us to mention, the only other bit of things he has done is kill Alex
at Portimao. So, I mean, that's not exactly, that's what they're known for. It doesn’t say a
lot about you as a driver. Yeah, if you're known for like, nuking people. And then, I mean, Egozi
was P2, he is still just there, but he impeded Al Azhari, so he got a 5 place grid drop, meaning
our favourite local Jamaican, Alex Powell, who is going to start on the front row. Yeah. If we get
to the race. Oh, sorry. Yeah, I mean, I think there's a lot of hope, because we've seen it already,
Alex has been, you know, he's been quite good this season, he's been a bit unlucky. But this time,
it's kind of his own doing, he stalled, which is really unfortunate, because he had the
pace, and had really good overtake skills. I think solid top five, maybe a podium, but
stalling from P2, that's just, you need to lock in and not do that. Yeah. I mean, I’m a Lando Norris fan.
I know the pain of bad starts. I lived through 2024. But hey, it can be fixed. I think maybe
Alex needs to talk to Lando, sort out this bad start, because it has been a few times where he's
qualified well, but he loses a few positions off the line, and that's just gonna- yeah he can get
this position back, but then you're wasting time, when he could be going forwards. Maybe that's why he
grew the goatee, he wanted to channel a bit more Lando Norris into his performance this weekend.
He got the wrong Lando, he needed Lando 2026, not Lando 2024.
Oh my god. The goatee that chose him. I mean, he still managed to get up to P11 on the road,
P10 after penalties, which just showed how much pace he had. And even despite the safety car,
like without the safety car, it could have been even higher. That just shows how good he is.
So I mean, please, Alex, I think for Robin's sanity in particular, sort it out. But other than
that, it is quite a calm race. I mean, we avoided the lap one, turn one pile up. Yeah. Turn one,
because normally turn one, I think just the way the corner is, especially like,
we saw in Italian F4, it was just so bad at that corner. Because this was how the corner is.
Even at FREC, it's so hard to race. It's just how the corner is structured. It makes you think
you can go two wide, but one car can just shove the other guy off. And it's just chaotic in general.
Yeah, FREC, it felt like every time they passed through that corner, somebody was causing a pile
up. And it was just, it was at least four cars affected. But this, for EC3, it was probably like
the least Monza, a Monza race could be. I like to think maybe after all the red flags in testing,
they got yelled at. Oh, yeah, for sure. Or at least mentally to themselves, they thought if we
if we were going to race. Especially if you think how expensive the crashes can get, because,
you know, remember, these drivers are, they aren't getting paid, they're paying to be there.
If they crash, they have to pay for that damage. That is a good deterrent. Like, oh, yeah, you make
this incredible- you make this move for P20 and now you have to pay however much a new sidepod
or whatever costs. And of course, it won't be a Formula Regional race without a ton of penalties
at the end of the race. I think it's how this always happens, how there are always so many penalties
for the most random things. Like, oh, yeah, they're using push to pass on the safety car.
How? Yeah. And they're like, super strict on when you use your push to pass. Obviously,
yes. But like on the safety car, what are you trying to do on the safety car? You can't overtake.
You can't overtake. You're not meant to be doing anything. Bustamante got a 10 second
time penalty for collisions with Caretti, which, I mean, I honestly forget she's there,
even though she's with Palou. She's like, I just forget she's there. I don't think she scored a
single point so far this season. Like, I just remember her when she gets- comes up an incident.
She also got a reprimand for starting her engine during the 5 and 1minute
board. They reset it and then she got another one for collision with car six. Not too sure who that
was. But no, it sounded like the Bianca Bustamante sideplot this weekend was quite fascinating.
6 is Kolovos. Of course, it's Kolovos. Kolovos is the same as Bustamante. He's only ever coming up
in incident reports and like different sort of reprimands and stuff. Making a name for yourself,
I guess. I just want to correct myself for one thing, Caretti. I’ve just been informed,
that using push to pass is when the safety car is in the pit, but before they cross the finish
line. I get what they're trying to do then, but still, you should know, don't hit the button
before that when they cross the line. It's a common rule. Yeah, it's not like an EC3 specific
thing. This is everywhere. I mean, unless it’s IndyCar. Oh, well, yeah. If you're Alex Palou,
you can do it. Why is Alex Palou everywhere? Alex Palou is everywhere and he's dominating
everywhere. Other penalties included Beckley, Harrison and Campos, the driver not the team,
got the same rep command as Bustamante for the engine. Campos also got a 10 second penalty
for not respecting yellow flags. Petrovic 10 seconds for leaving the track and getting an
advantage. And Trappa 10 seconds for causing a collision. A lot of penalties. And after this,
you know, whatever, of course we had to have a wet qualifying for the next day.
Yeah, of course. And I mean, I wish they live streamed qualifying, like we get to watch
FREC qualifying. It's also like we have so many questions, like, how did this end? What happened
to Heuzeroeder? Because Alex was only P15. But then with that [...] he didn’t get a lap in,
we don't know. Did he make a mistake? We don't know. It was funny as well, because as I was
watching the live timing, you know how they show the finish flag for when the session has ended?
Like literally as that came down, Heuzeroeder just stopped at T1, T2. And I was like,
of course he stopped at T1, T2. And then I checked the positioning and everyone was trying to start
a flying lap. But because he was there and there were local yellows, no one could. Yeah, I mean,
I think he's just in the Schumacher meme, done for the day. That was him. He just gave up.
But I wonder, it was just against Fiorentino, as he calls the red flag, that causes stop,
stop and start. It's just, it just gets like a lot. And we had El Feghali on pole, I believe.
Yes, it was El Feghali. Second pole of the season. But it's good for him. He does endear me a bit.
Yeah, same. I don't know, I just like it. I just find it cool with drivers from smaller nations.
There's something about that. It's just really cool. Because of course, you know,
I'd say, of drivers, you know, the European- It's very European. And then have like
America, Australia, those are quite common nations. But then Lebanese, like what other
Lebanese drivers do even, can't think of any other Lebanese drivers. And El Feghali himself,
he's doing like pretty well, as well. He's got a win, he's got a few poles. He's doing
solid, and I mean, I feel like maybe a second season next year for him could do a title challenge.
I'm not even too sure what his plans are, but I've not seen him rumored for F3, so I feel like-
El Feghali feels like one of those drivers that kind of need to do another season in regional.
See if he can take the title. Yeah. And then, [...?[
Bustamante got a 10-place grid drop for her aforementioned three place-, three reprimands.
But she qualified second last. The only one behind her was the guy who was on his second lap.
And the funny thing is, she's only got dropped one position, which means for starting [...?],
nine places carried over the next weekend to the next weekend. But I feel like she's always going
too bad, but are they going to keep on carrying over, like, oh, you're a P28 again? Is she going
to have to drop next time? Or is she going to serve two places each time? How long does this go on
for? I feel like she's always qualifying towards the back. Yeah, definitely. I don't know if she's
going to be able to finish all of them. Will it carry over to next year, then? For her sake,
I hope it does. But, no, for her sake, I hope it doesn't, but, you know. It'd be funny. I mean,
people are just messing up, because even with the, there was an incident between Strauven and Trappa,
but the, uh, Campos filed against Egozi instead of Trappa, so the stewards didn't accept it.
Paperwork error. Because Egozi is car 48 and Trappa is car 84. Maybe they’re a
bit dyslexic. They just messed up the numbers. I'd be so pissed. I'd be so pissed if I was
Strauven , and I was like, okay, there's going to be an incident against the guy, and then it's like,
oh, sorry, man, we put in the wrong number. Oh, yeah, because that's it. Like, how do you,
how does that happen? And nobody's checking the document? Or is everybody just dyslexic?
Yeah, no, that's what I was asking. I was like, has no one checked the docs before they sent it
off to the stewards? Bro, I'd be so pissed. I'd be, like, fighting someone. Yeah, and then,
I mean, the race, this race was, I enjoyed this race more than the first race. Let's be like,
this gave us more, kind of just chaos. Whatever was, I'm not too sure. It was just, stuff is
happening. Of course, our favorite American, Egozi won. Oh, he's our favorite American? Okay.
I mean, because Alex Powell is Jamaican, he’s not under the American flag, but he's Jamaican,
so remember, the Jamaican sensation. The Jamaican sensation. Yeah, speaking of that, I,
I still do miss Jake Sanson. Please bring him back. No offense, I don't like the,
this new commentator just lacks the energy. There's two of them, which make it worse.
They’re too nonchalant. They're constantly, like, they're not conversating about the right things.
As much as I do love, like, this podcast, like, I've, multiple times, I think I've compared them
to us, which is fine for us, but not fine for them. That's their job. I mean, what are we?
We aren't exactly, we aren't being paid, we aren't professionals. We're just, like,
feeder series. I feel like if I was commentating, at least put some emotion,
I really like Sanson's emotion. That is one thing I really liked about him. I could tell
he was really passionate. And I think also because he commented on the karting, because he knew a lot
of the drivers personally when they were kids. And just the whole thing was so nice and, like,
you could tell he's genuinely rooted for everyone. Yeah. Yeah. And Sanson, like, knows his stuff.
Oh, yeah. And he's just a really nice guy. And I hope you get, please, I mean, I know you’re not going to
listen to this, but Jake Sanson, please come back. We miss you. We miss you. Please. Please.
Because, I mean, I just feel like he only commentated, like, I remember, I think it was
at the end of the first race when Egozi came to the lead. They noticed it. It's just like,
oh, yeah, he's leading. Put some emotion into it. Be excited that he's leading.
He comes from P17 to P1. Please, okay, yay, Egozi kind of expects that, but have some excitement.
It's a move for the lead. That should always be exciting. Also, why did the TV direction
barely kind of miss that move? The TV direction misses everything. Yeah, it won't be a Grand Prixquel
episode without us complaining about the TV direction, but it was just all over the place.
It's like, especially in these races when there's a lot happening at the front,
please focus on the front. There's a lot happening over there, especially, I mean,
we had four wide running. We had the, in fighting in the Paloiu with Perard and Dall’Agnol,
where I think Perard, his right rear was, like, broken, and Feghali had contact. Everybody just
got out. Yeah, this was a Monza race. I mean, we love Monza. This is why we love Monza.
I think they maybe, they missed out on the chaos on race one. They were like race two.
Let's make this the most Monza race ever. But everyone, like, who was not involved in an
incident? Who did not get caught up in anything, apart from bloody Egozi? To be fair, I'm pretty
sure Egozi also had something. There was something that he did, and I remember people were like,
well, yeah, I don't remember. Yeah, I mean, even Alex, he made it up to P5, maybe P4 after
penalty, but even he had an issue with Trappa. Yeah. And then we had, I don't know, Feldmann was
in P6, Petrovic was out, but Harrison, of course, he's spinning people. Tye was out. Everyone was
just all over the place. I do want to compliment Feldman for getting up into a points paying
position before he had his unfortunate spin with, was it Harrison and Tye? Yeah, Harrison and Tye.
I mean, he had a P13 in the first race, which for him, I remember during the UAE4 races,
in the Middle East, they were like, oh, Nato again, what's he going to do? Yeah. He's finally,
you know, he seems to have improved, which, I mean, he's less accident prone, now he's just gotta get
a little bit faster. Yeah, I do feel very upset that after he did this duringone of the FREMT
races, I don't know, I don't remember which one, but he like threw his gloves onto the grass. He
was stomping, the marshals are trying to calm him down. I was like, I feel really bad for him
because yeah, it's a P6. And like the commentators said, P6 is yeah, it's basically a win for him,
especially when you're away from a lower team, when they keep pitting against, you know, the Campos
Palou, there's not much room for the other teams. Yeah, but here we had eight retirements
in that race, which of course we did. I mean, I think a third of the grid retired. Yeah. And
penalties, we started with classified [?], but he was three laps down. I mean, that's basically a DNF
then. I mean, I'm hoping to see more of Tommy Harfield. I kind of forgot he was racing. Yeah,
he's irrelevant. I do quite like him, but he's stressful. He's a sweet kid. And I quite like
he's doing this thing where he's like supporting children with special needs. Yeah, he's doing this.
Let me look at him. He's actually really, it's actually really cool. I think what he's doing.
Man, that's actually sweet. Oh, yeah. But let me find it. Give me a moment. He's becoming
an ambassador for Sensory Pitstops, which who support neurodivergent fans at every race weekend and
like make race weekends more accessible. Like that is so sweet and cool. That's amazing. Good,
good on him. I want to see him do well, because you know, it's cool to see drivers supporting
initiatives like that, especially when they're like no young feeder series, you don't normally
expect to see that. And but I feel like for him, it's more about getting experience this year,
he's doing alongside British F4. So it's not his main campaign. Maybe next year we'll see
more. And it wouldn't be a Formula Regional race without a bunch of penalties. So Feldman got
five places for causing the collision. Kolovos, Strauven, Dall’Agnol got ten
seconds. Bostandjiev. Bostandjiev, yeah. Got 10 seconds for using push to pass in the safety car.
Struaven started using it 13 seconds before the finish line. Well, what are you doing? That's a whole,
basically a whole half sector to go. Trappa got a reprimand for wearing a smartwatch.
There was an enquiry lost between Feghali and Dall’Agnol, but Dall’Agnol got a three place grid
drop anyway. Al Azhari got a one place drop for race 2, for looking to take over the Feghali off
track and also lost his fastest lap. Powell got a reprimand for pushing Trappa off track.
And Eyckmans got a reprimand for moving erratically ahead of Trappa. I think Trappa’s just been a
victim. Why’s he just in everything? I think because Trappa’s also like, he's one of those drivers
that he's up there, but he's not, he's like in the thick of it. You know, he's in the points
paying positions, but he's like always near everyone else. So everyone else has got to like
get past him, but he's just there. Yeah, I mean, I did quite enjoy it. I feel like race two is just
hard to describe, there's so much going on and I feel like we barely got any racing done,
because there was just stuff happening the whole time. Very enjoyable to watch though. I feel like
we had like, we had like three different times that we changed leaders for this race. Very cool
to watch. I love racing. And we had to watch, at the end, look, Al Azhari was leading at one point,
and where did he end up finishing in the final classification? It'd be like eighth in the end,
I think. Yeah. I mean, that just happens at Monza, because it's such a good track,
you can really overtake at Monza. So because of how cool- we have the long straights, the corners,
the braking zones, you just make it so easy to overtake. A bit too easy, I think. Do you
have anything else to say about the races, or should we move on to the championship?
The championship standings, I really like seeing these.
Yeah, so we have Egozi and- Okay, I think before we do that, Robin has told us she wants us to
glaze Alex for a bit. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, he had a really good redemption. I mean, after this,
after the unfortunate race one, he hacked from P15 to P4. He kept it relatively
clean, apart from that incident with Trappa. Oh got reprimanded for it. And like, if he
lost a bit more at the end, he could have been on the podium if Sztuka wouldn't overtake him at the
end. And like, he'll still be after, I mean, he likes Monza, he said. Alex, are you Alex monzabanking
in disguise? Do you have something to tell us, either one of you? I mean, well,
it's funny how Alex had to miss this episode. He knew we were gonna ask him, is he Alex Powell
in disguise? But I mean, I mean, for Alex, it's just been an up and down, like, it's been an
unfortunate season for him, because he's had the pace, and he's always been there in the points,
it’s just Campos have been a**. There's no nicer way to put it. It's really because they've normally
been the team to beat. Whereas this year, they've just not been it at all. And it's been like all
their drivers, it's just been a shame. And I think it's Alex, he's the best Campos. I mean,
he consistently is. Yeah, consistently is. And it's like, he's pushing the car as far as he can
go. And we've seen a lot of things. And I feel like last, he's really improved from last year, especially
his race craft. He's been able to make places up. Yeah. He's always been really, really good at
overtaking. I think we've just seen this very much so. He's been forced to. Yeah, his teammates also
quite crash prone. So yeah, but the main thing he can do is think I think he's talking about the
standings. He is the highest place Campos car. Mm hmm. Because you have one-, his team
mates are what? We have Strauven in 12th, Heuzenroeder in 9th, Tarnvanichkul in 14th. He's way ahead
of them. I mean, and he's been unfortunate. He got taken out in back to back races in Portimao.
Yeah, but I mean, it goes Egozi’s lead though. He's actually insane. He leads by 93 points.
That's four rounds left. I did the maths earlier. So he can win it in Jerez when there's two rounds
left. So to win in Jerez, that’s with Hungary. And that's where the last two races left. He needs
a 110 point lead. He currently leads by 93 points. He just needs to gain 17 points in the next two
races to win it two rounds early. Which I think is totally possible for him. He's just been
so dominant. It's crazy to see. I mean, so far, there have only been two races where he's not been
on the podium. One of which he was leading and his engine just exploded. It Mechachrome’d.
But other than that, I mean, so far in what? I'm trying to... I mean, so far out of what, 10 races,
he's won six of them. Like this streak is actually insane. He's just been so consistent
and the pace. And yes, maybe the
Campos, the Prema is good, but he's still a level above his teammate. I mean, Dall’Agnol is fifth,
and his teammate is fifth. Yeah. He's still doing like, he's outperforming everyone else by a lot.
Honestly though, the MP guys are all kind of there. I mean, Eyckmans and Lammers.
They're second and third, they're a long way off Egozi. And then you have the Hitech
of Al Azhari in fourth. There's a good mix of teams in the top six. You have four different
teams in Palou, MP, Hitech. Al Azhari  is really falling off his other start. It seemed like he
could be the one to maybe challenge Egozi. But he's just not been getting the results he needed.
Yeah. And Al Azhari has also been involved with a number of on-track incidents. And so, I think
just from that sort of showing, it's just like, you know. He also has, I think,
the Alex Powell curse of stalling. I mean, both of these, I mean, I don't know,
Alex seems to lose pace with it. Al Azhari just seems to stall. I mean, it's quite funny. It's
interesting how much stalls do happen in feeder series. It's just how they're releasing
the clutch or something. It is such a common issue. Like, I wonder if anything can be done
to fix this issue. We're continuing on on the standings. Yeah, we have Eyckman on 100 points,
Lammers on 89, Al Azhari on 86, Dall’Agnol. I'm sorry, I don't know how to say his names.
I think it's Dall’Agnol.
Dall’Agnol, yeah.
Szuka tied on 62 points with Alex ahead, due to his P2 in Imola.
But Szuka thinks he’s ahead, so who’s gonna tell Kacper he’s not ahead? Who’s gonna break the news to him? Cause someone needs to. Like you’ll see his Twitter post where,
Yeah, it's like his own, it's his own graphic too, that Twitter post, isn't it?
Where he's put himself ahead of Alex. Someone's going to need to tell him. It's okay, he'll find
out. Yeah, I'm going to try to find the post. He has himself sixth, yeah, I mean, who's going to tell
him? I mean, he's done really well, given he's in a Technicar, but also, given his
experience in F3, you're going to kind of expect a lot of performance from him because he is a lot more.
I mean, he's been around in feeder series a lot the last few years. I mean, he won Italian F4
back in 2023, then into a year of F3, then he did FRECA last year. He's just all over the place.
He's been doing a lot. I think it's just due to funding, this sort of thing. I mean, I do wonder
what a few of his drivers are doing next year. Like, it goes here, imagine him in F3, it's going
to be insane. Like, I do wonder who's going to step up to F3. I mean, Powell, I'd love to see
Powell in F3 as well. Yes. Okay, we are entering the summer break, all these rumors are flying
around about who's going where. Some drivers are being quite abashed about it. Seb Wheldon.
Anyways, I wonder where Seb Wheldon’s going. It's really a big mystery. I don't know.
Who would have thought? Not like he's posting cars, like he's posting a test on his story.
Yeah, on his TikTok story. I mean, it's so obvious he's going to be racing for,
he's going to be with AIX next year. It's so obvious.
Yeah, but I mean, with the goods start to take shape, I mean, slowly we're all going to start
to have some announcements. It's going to be fascinating. Yeah. Just with how the good ends
up. Like, Alex Powell in a Campos, like, please get that guy in a top seat. And realistically,
you want to be in a Campos or a Trident. And he's already got the Campos thing going on, so
would love to see him in a car that is consistently fighting at the front.
And there aren't many Red Bull Juniors who can take the Campos seats. I feel like, apart from
McLaughlin, what other Red Bull Juniors do we see stepping up? I feel like Colnaghi could step up
to F2, or maybe he'll do F3, but still leaves an F3 seat free. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, please just leave
a seat free for Alex. I mean, unless you're in a Campos or a Trident, you can't really compete
for the title. That's just how it's been. Maybe in something like an MP or another team like that,
you can maybe get some side finishers, but. Yeah, maybe a Rodin. Yeah, I mean, the title
fight is looking so interesting because we're probably going to have Wheldon and KNB in Trident.
Put Alex into the Campos and Italian F4 2024 2.0, 2025 Italian F4. I mean,
this podcast though. We're all going to be fighting each other then.
We're all going to block each other by the end of this. If we've not blocked each other
by the time FREC ends, we're going to block each other by the time F3 starts.
Oh no, I think FREC we’re already beefing in FREC for all, I mean, except,
except for Seb versus Olivieri versus KNB. It’s not looking good for us, but hey.
But on a real note, we show how you can support different drivers and still vaguely get on.
Robin still asks to hold my hand every other race, so we're still friends, I think. I mean,
we're just going to have to see. I mean, we may only get to see F3. I mean, it depends. They're
fighting. If one of them crashes into the other for the win, maybe then we'll have different
opinions. Maybe. We'll just have to see next year. So, I mean, if you agree with us having fights next
year, join the Alex Powell Campos agenda. I think those are the most
three drivers, and of course Egozi, I'd love to see him in F3 and what he can do, because.
I mean, before this, I mean, if you saw me on the EC3 Winter Series recap, I called him a
winter series merchant, which aged incredibly well. That is probably my greatest prediction to date.
See, I'd love to see what he could do as well, even as an Eyckmans to Lammers. He says, I think
Eyckmans to Lammers may do another year of EC3, because they have, especially Strauven. Strauven’s
really disappointed me this year. I feel like they may do another year of EC3,
and Sztuka, maybe he's going to go backwards. Maybe he's going to do,
he's going to do German F4 next year, maybe. Yes, German F4. And in the team's championship,
it's no surprise that it's Palou leading. I mean, when it goes to 193 points, it's inevitable
Palou’s going to be leading. They're on 285 points. Then MP on 207, Campos on 138,
Hitech on 120, and Technicar on 62. Yeah, I mean, apart from Campos and Hitech,
nobody's close to each other in the top five in the standings.
Yeah, and I don't think this is, while I do think there'll be a shift, maybe, around like
the Campos-Hitech area, I really don't think there'll be a shift between
anyone else. It's just the gaps are too big. Yeah. I've said that on the podcast now,
they're going to nuke themselves. Who are you talking to? I think if Campos end up doing worse,
I think Robin is actually going to murder you. Yeah. Going to come find you.
I'm just going to get the voice like DM at like 3am and Rob's at my door. Sorry in advance, Rob.
Yeah, I mean, I just love EC3. I can't lie, before the season I didn’t follow it much. I think Robin
is possibly at fault, actually why I'm following it so much, thanks to Alex Powell. I can't lie,
if that's not because of Alex Powell, are anyone going to care about EC3? I mean, we just go where
our favorite drivers go. I mean, I only watched GB3 last year for Freddie, the races he did.
Like, wherever Freddie’s racing, I'll watch. I mean, it's just inevitable, like,
you'll watch wherever Kean’s going to race. Yeah, I didn’t watch FREC last year because it was too late
and then now I have to. I mean, I just watched, the only thing with me is because I'm working
so many weekends after I watched the races on, like, the Monday after. Like, even this,
I was working this weekend so I had to watch the races on, like, yesterday. I can't watch anything
live. Yeah, I mean, other than the EC3 this week, the main other action we had was, of course,
the final round of the FIA European Karting Championships. Yeah, I don't want to mention
it briefly because we crowned our champion, so in OK Junior we had Will Green, and in OK
we had Noah Baglin. Couldn't we have came to be British in karting? I mean, it was quite,
it was quite inevitable both of them were going to win their respective championships due to their
lead in the standings. I mean, I'm really excited for Baglin. I don't know if I've mentioned him
before on the pod, but I think he's a great talent and it could be so much fun to see him in F4 next
year. We aren't going to see him doing any winter series as he only turns 15 in March next year.
Sure, but, I mean, he said he's going to do F4 next year. We're probably going to see it in Italian
F4 next year. Ferrari Junior. He's going to be with Prema. I feel like he's inevitable. He's going
to be with Prema F4 next year. Oh yeah, especially just as an FDA member. As an FDA member you sign
your soul to Ferrari and Prema for your first year of single seater. Yeah, I mean, in F4, I mean,
they aren't as bad as they are in F2 and F3. It's mainly, maybe mainly due just to F4
not being as strong. I think it's interesting to see where I think Green and he’s probably going
to do okay karting next year. But I think there are two names to certainly watch in the world of
karting. But like even with the FDA thing, Filippo Sala rumored for Spanish F4 with Campos. So maybe
they're all due to the Prema downfall. Yeah. No one's going as expected because, you know,
Beganvoic has completely left Prema. And so has Camara. I mean, Beganovic, and Tapponen is not
with Prema at all. Is he still with the FDA, Tapponen? Yes, he is, don't worry. Yeah, Weug [?]
was the one who got swapped. The ex-FDA member is the one with Prema. Maccagnani is the only current
FDA member with Prema. I mean, I mean, Baglin was with Prema in karting until they dropped out.
Yeah, so was Green actually. I mean, what is it? I mean, Prema, they are a good karting team and
they have to be where the top drivers end up. Yeah, I don't watch much of the karting world,
I can only mention it a bit. And because it is good racing, I do recommend watching any karting
races. It can be fun. I mean, I don't even watch the older kids when I watch minis. I'm like,
these kids are like nine years old and that freaks me out a bit. Oh yeah, the kid that karting.
Yeah, they're like, it's like, watch your old, like your favorite driver. They came through
karting and watch them be successful. I've watched some of Freddie’s old races. I'm sure
I've even seen some of Lando's and I mean, they all started somewhere. And ultimately,
if they're in single seaters and doing well, they're going to have a good karting record.
Yeah. And I think that's it for this week. Thank you everyone for listening to this week's episode
of the Grand Prixquel Podcast. Let us know your favorite moment from this week's action at Monza.
We'd love to hear your opinions. As long as it's positive towards Alex Powell. And don't forget
to follow us @grandprixquel on all platforms, and until next week where we're also going to find out
what we're covering next week due to this being the proper summer break. There's all major series
aren't racing, so unless you really love Nordic 4, there's not much to tune into next week.